2018 年法國訂國家 AI 戰略
用的就是這個人帶隊寫的報告
他叫 Cédric Villani
2010 年的費爾茲獎得主
後來當了五年國會議員
今年 9 月 11 號
他跟另外 24 位得主聯名發表聲明
說 AI 公司搶著拿數學難題當跑分
正在傷害數學
聲明發出 4 天後
9 月 15 號早上
他上了法國一家古典音樂電台的晨間專訪
AI 幾天就能解掉懸了幾十年的難題
數學家到底在怕什麼
他用一間教室來回答
不得不說，AI 現在已經會解
非常複雜的數學方程式
像最近的 Navier-Stokes 問題
Villani，您為什麼擔心？
為什麼偏偏是這一題，讓您的同行開始擔心？
首先，您提到同行，說得沒錯
我在這裡講的，甚至不是我自己的意見
而是一整群費爾茲獎得主的意見
25 位費爾茲獎得主，超過多數…
超過在世得主的一半
這麼多得主一起站出來說話，以前從來沒有過
說他們很擔心
起因是幾天前，9 月 8 日那件事
一連串的宣布又反宣布
一邊是跟 Anthropic 合作的團隊，一邊是跟 OpenAI 合作的團隊
最後，解出來了，宣布了，也發表了
是流體力學裡的幾道難題
在整個數學界都數一數二有名
其中一題是 Euler 方程，可以說懸了 250 年
一題是您剛剛提到的 Navier-Stokes 方程
7 道千禧年難題之一，懸賞 100 萬美元
這些都是數學家一直在做的題目
讀你們那份聲明，看得出來
走到答案的那條路，也許跟答案一樣重要
這就是你們要捍衛的
你們捍衛找答案花的時間，就跟捍衛答案這座聖杯一樣
找的時間，驗證答案的時間
還有弄懂它的時間
那條路甚至更重要，在科學裡常常是這樣
在數學裡尤其如此，比結果本身還重要
這幾個月，我們看到一些 AI 工具
在數學上強到
一眨眼就能解掉
原本要用幾十年來算的題目
就拿 Navier-Stokes 這一題來說
OpenAI 用 88 小時的運算跟摸索
靠這些強大的演算法
解掉一道懸了 90 年、在數學界很有代表性的題目
然後只花 17 小時，就用機器驗證完
相比之下，人類辛辛苦苦做了 4 年
才把 2002 年那個解答驗證完
那是我們的千禧年難題，龐加萊猜想
Villani，您跟您那些拿費爾茲獎的同行
還有整個科學界
我想物理學家、天文物理學家，所有做研究的人也一樣
你們擔心，是不是因為覺得
「我們會變成汽車出現時的馬車夫」？
您擔心的是這個嗎？是為了保住自己這一行？
首先，這個比喻有它的極限
我在這件事上看到的是
年輕一代還更擔心
比我們這些資深的、像我這樣的人更擔心
我們職位、獎項，該有的都有了
在數學裡，要讓事情往前走
要進步、要更懂這個世界
需要三樣最基本的原料
點子、學生，還有題目
一千年來，往前走的方法
就是出題目給學生
讓他們把那些點子弄得更懂
好讓他們長出新點子、提出新題目
新題目再拿去訓練下一批學生，一直這樣下去
現在，我們手上的工具厲害到
題目有枯竭的風險
想像一下，你是老師，你班上
有一個人比其他人都強太多太多
找答案特別快
你題目一出，他馬上給答案
別人連想的時間都沒有
班上總有一個人比別人先舉手
有一個就算了，可是這一個，別人還來不及想
其他學生會進步嗎？
答案是：不太會
我們需要花時間在習題上
才會弄懂、才會長出新點子
這件事，從小學
到寫博士論文，甚至更後面，都一樣
主持人接著提到
AI 大廠裡也有人出來示警
說 AI 越來越危險、管不住
還會自作主張，十年內可能會變壞
他問 Villani 同不同意
「自作主張」這個詞，我不會拿來講 AI
AI 從來只做程式設定它去做的事
可是它能做的事那麼多
又能鑽進
我們這個數位社會的每一道縫隙
所以，對，只要看看新聞
就知道風險有各式各樣
各種危險，有安全問題
有武器的問題、技術的問題
工作的問題，各種控制不住的問題
我們這些數學家，最想說的是
小心，我們先花時間想一想
我們這一行，什麼才重要
別讓年輕數學家變成失落的一代
也別讓文化乾涸，那會傷到全人類
這是今天數學界的事
今天所有的文化活動，也都碰到同一個問題
主持人再問，物理學家、天文學家
甚至人文學科
會不會都碰到同一個問題
當然，人文學科也可以算進來
您看，現在一個 AI、一個演算法
就能幫你寫出一篇還過得去的論文
幾乎什麼題目都行，幾秒鐘就寫好
一位在劍橋教數學的朋友跟我說
「現在，博士生頭兩年會被問到的題目
AI 差不多都解得出來」
在這種情況下，怎麼讓學生還有動力，才是最重要的
我剛收了一個博士生
我特別交代他，念博士這段期間，還在養成的時候
千萬不要用那些生成式工具
養成的時候，就是要下苦功
把自己的腦袋重新塑造一遍
任何一門專業，美就美在這裡
不管你是藝術家、天文物理學家、哲學家還是數學家
你都要花時間重新塑造自己的腦袋
把自己變成人類派去那片領域探索的代表
我記得 10 年前有個人跟我說
念書就是要吃點苦，念書就是關在四面牆裡
一群人聚在牆裡面，一起絞盡腦汁
這個人甚至跟我說，每個禮拜一開始
準備考理工、數學學院入學考的那段時間
禮拜一先煮好一鍋湯
每天去買一條新鮮的長棍麵包
然後就關在書房裡不出來
那個人就是您吧？
對，沒錯，那是我在寫一本數學書的時候
那本書在我人生裡變成一件很重要的事
後來這本書拿到美國數學學會的 Doob 獎
因為它講得特別好懂又完整
那些埋頭苦幹的日子、那些痛苦的日子
我整天就是湯和書，書和湯
那是痛苦，也是幸福
您講的這些，跟現在完全對不上
這個社會講休閒、講享樂
要快速解答，人手一支手機
您是在逆流划船
是啊，我在划，我就是故意逆著划，我要說的是
要快樂，要過得好
就得花時間、花力氣
去做一件你真正在乎的事
花時間、花力氣，這不是什麼新道理
您一定記得《小王子》的作者聖修伯里
是你花在照顧那朵花的時間，讓它變得珍貴
諸如此類
你花越多時間、越多力氣去攻克一道題目
你就越自豪、越快樂
Villani 擔心的是
AI 把題目解得太快
學生就沒有題目可以自己慢慢磨
所以他交代剛收的博士生
念博士這幾年
先別讓生成式工具替你想
原影片 12 分鐘
後面他還聊了兩件事
一件是教育
有人說有了 AI 就不用念書了
他說聽到這種話太可怕
另一件是他在巴黎劇場的演出
把數學講座跟詩朗誦混在一起
他順手舉了一個例子
一顆球切成 5 塊
能拼回兩顆跟原來一樣大的球
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。